josée legault alec castonguay stéphanie
grammond bonsoir
j'ai une petite hésitation je regardais
mes notes chaudes avec quoi je commence
qu est ce qui ressort de ce rapport
de la commissaire à la santé madame
castonguay québec mal préparé une
évidence
manque de main-d'oeuvre solution l'a
beaucoup dit gouvernance défaillante la
gouvernance en général du réseau
perception d'un manque d'indépendance
chez lassante sur la santé publique ça
c'est intéressant
intéressant on en a beaucoup parlé accès
aux données difficile donc pas savoir
exactement qu'est ce qui accroît des
matches le nombre de résidents ben vous
voyez un certain nombre de résumer mais
moi ce que j'ai retenu en fait la phrase
que j'ai retenu c'est le leadership est
insuffisant des parts du leadership au
gouvernement aussi et qu' il n'y avait
pas de l'anti année j'ai trouvé amusant
l'expression il n'y avait pas de l'anti
aînés comme si on n'avait pas été
capable de voir ce qu'on aurait dû voir
c'est-à-dire que les personnes âgées
courant un risque énorme bon ça c'est
mon résumé josé à vous
laisse un excellent résumé pour le dire
c'est sûr que c'est un rapport qui nous
laisse quand même peu sur notre faim
c'est un rapport qui est assez
bureaucratiques qui va pas du tout non
plus n'a vraiment là profondément à la
chaîne de commandement c'est pour ce que
c'est contrairement à ce que dit la
commissaire à la santé ça milite encore
plus pour
mais ouais voilà mais la lentille est né
on sait qu'elle est peut-être tout à
fait absente le résultat en est la
preuve il ya quand même des chiffres qui
frappe très fort 64 % des décès au
québec par la première vague était des
personnes résident soit en ch et celle
des en ressources intermédiaires ou en
ressources pour aînés
c'est énorme sur un peu près 5000
personne donc c'est pour ça qu'on
utilise le terme hécatombe et c'est
beaucoup plus élevé que dans le reste du
canada proportionnellement par là mais
pour le reste
bon oui la santé publique les crs à
quelle date ou si le manque
d'indépendance vous savez que le
directeur national de la santé publique
qui s'appelle horatio à vous donne et
voyous qui que ce soit d'autre 9 mm par
rapport aux partis d'opposition alors
imaginez encore moins la population ce
sont des aberrations
et ça aurait pu jouer un rôle mais c'est
c'est un élément parmi une brochette de
trucs parce que alec pour donné le
contexte quand monsieur legault se
faisait questionner et se fait toujours
questionné sur la tenue ou pas d'une
enquête publique indépendante hills et
oui mais attention la commissaire à la
santé madame castonguay on a confiance à
un
connaisseur elle a tous les pouvoirs
bien va faire une grosse partie du
travail avez-vous l'impression qu'elle a
faim effectivement une grosse partie du
travail qu'en pensez vous
je pense que en fait ça s'ajoute au
travail qui est fait en même temps et
que ça commence à concordé pas mal le
résumé que vous en avez fait
patrice c il n'y a pas beaucoup de
choses surprenantes pourquoi parce que
la protectrice du citoyen et arriver à
peu près aux mêmes conclusions
j'ai en tout cas mais l'accord n'est pas
encore remis son rapport avec ce qu'on a
entendu dans ces audiences exactement
dans le même sens que ce que joe
armstrong est conclu on est rendu donc
deux enquêtes probablement trois qui ont
documenté cette crise nous dans les chu
et celle des pis s'il pas mal tout le
temps la même affaire qui revient on
n'était pas préparé au ministère de la
santé on se concentrait sur les hôpitaux
pas sur les ch et celle d'e.on a fait
des courses lacunes en prévention contre
les infections main d'oeuvre tout ce que
vous avez dit est vrai d'abord ce
rapport là en plus juste à le souligner
la sas et le clou dans le cercueil de la
version daniel méthane sont on va
s'entendre là-dessus là c'est le
deuxième report et il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de témoins qui disent on n'a
pas investi les chs elle dès la fin du
mois de janvier on n'est pas qu'on n'a
rien fait avant la fin mars pour que les
sécher s'est elle déçoit vraiment après
donc ça au moins on l'éclaircît seul on
sait qui est exagéré danger en camel et
c'est pour marguerite blais qui dit
effectivement ce qui en étaient puis
c'est pas mal ce qui s'est passé puis
pour le reste johan castonguay rappelle
à quel point
il ya eu tellement de rapports sur les
seiches sld qui ont pas été mises en
application au fil des vingt trente
dernières années que ce presque un échec
collectif parce que on n'a juste pas mis
en place toutes les éléments qu'on
savait être pertinent et qu'ils ont
explosé en plein visage on la produit
stéphanie qu'est-ce que vous comment
vous résumer ça vous quelqu'un vous
demande si
c'est sûr que de résumer 300 pages 5 ans
avec minutes s'est jamais simple mais
moi je pense que ce que je dirais c'est
que c'est la preuve qu'on n'était pas
prêts on le voit de parler chiffres en
fait au lieu de tirer les leçons de la
crise 2 h à 1h qui avait eu lieu et dix
ans plus tôt en se préparant mieux on a
fait les verts sont à on a commencé au
québec à investir de moins en moins en
santé publique en fait le québec est la
province où on investit le moins dans
par rapport à l'ensemble de nos dépenses
en santé donc finalement 2% toutes les
autres provinces en mettre plus et on
est la seule province au 6 ou 7 parleurs
qui est accordée à la santé publique a
diminué depuis dix ans donc cesser les
chiffres sont là différence est énorme
parce que nous ici par capita s'adonne
118 dollars alors qu'au canada on est
plutôt autour de 300 puis dans les pays
de l' ocde c'est 200 dollars dont 7 ça
fait une grosse différence
et puis quand on canton aux voix aura
sur la rue des acquis qui quittent qui
laisse découvrir le gouvernement ya
quelqu'un bon on peut dire ben d'accord
mais c'est peut-être le navire sur
lequel yvon guay qui a besoin d'être
dans son ensemble
la seule république de donner un coup de
barre
sas a pas été compris c'est ce que
jamais compris la csu et josé en a parlé
un peu à la question démarcation qui
croyez-vous néanmoins après tout
l'exercice que vous avez fait qu'on a
besoin au québec d'un exercice un autre
une enquête publique voici sa réponse
honnêtement
je pense que entre le rapport de la
protectrice du citoyen le rapport à
venir du coroner et nos rapports on a
tout ce qu'il faut pour s'engager dans
une transformation puis regarder vers
l'avenir est vraiment temps qu'on passe
à l'amélioration de notre système de
santé pour faire face aux crises futures
mais aussi pour améliorer sa performance
dans tout un jeu passe dans l'autre sens
ce tour de table drapée de là dessus
qu'en pensez vous de sa réponse les fans
et
mais oui c'est vrai que là on commence à
voir de plus en plus de de gens qui
témoignent et qui disent non ce n'est
pas nécessaire c'est vrai que l'ampleur
de la crise dicte est d'avoir une
réponse est importante aussi de faire le
tour de la question de sens que pour par
respect pour les gens qui sont décédés
leur entourage
maintenant c'est vrai que on a de plus
en plus une enquête qui qui viennent
mettre tous les morceaux dipose au bon
endroit et que si on faisait une
commission ben ça ça prendrait sa
mobiliserait et tout le système de santé
pendant peut-être deux plus sait-on
jamais
[Musique]
vous vous rangez vous vers cette
opinion le sait de plus en plus
déchirant déchira alec
moi je suis d'accord avec madame
castonguay ce jeu fait partie des
sceptiques depuis un bon moment parce
que si on fait une enquête publique qui
on le dit souvent c'est pour comprendre
les mécanismes ce qui s'est produit et
non pas pour trouver des coupables pour
qu'éventuellement ça ne se reproduise
plus qu'on améliore la situation je
pense qu'avec le rapport de mammouth est
convié le rapport de la protectrice du
citoyen celui qui va venir de madame
kamel les tout ce qui a été écrit on a
quand même pas mal compris ce qui doit
être amélioré et changer son bilan quel
public parce qu'on veut trouver des
coupables ça c'est une autre chose les
partis d'opposition aimerait bien sûr
que ça monopolise l'attention et les
médias aussi ça serait quand même
intéressant mais si l'objectif c'est de
modifier le réseau de la santé pour que
les ch et celle dé la prochaine fois
soit mieux équipés honnêtement c'est
seul objectif je pense qu'on a les
réponses josé
belge est obligé d'être de tout autre
ascq justement parce que ça fait à peu
près 25 juin
au québec on a eu plein de rapport donne
aussi de mémoire qui ont été déposés des
alertes ont été sonnés à répétition
concernant les sièges et celle des haies
et tout ce matériel est atterri au même
endroit dans une vaste déchiqueteuse ou
houda les oubliés du parlement je ne
sais pas trop où et je crains que celui
de madame castonguay va allez vous aussi
les rejoindre et c'est pour ça que ça
prenne que une vraie comme si on a
quelques indépendante et élargie pour
que premièrement on aille au fond des
choses et et c'est pas une question de
trouver des coupables mais il ya une
imputabilité aussi des décideurs et si
j'étais les partis d'opposition je ferai
attention aussi parce que ça va toucher
des libéraux ça va toucher les péquistes
parce que la négligence des chs ldl en
amont et date aussi de leur gouvernement
mais c'est important qu'on le sachant
que le processus de 6 et juste une
dernière chose oui c'est seulement une
commission denquête comme la commission
par comme la commission parent aussi sur
la dpj qui peut justement produire un
rapport en profondeur des
recommandations précises et là on peut
faire le suivi ensuite est ce que ces
recommandations là sont vraiment à
draguer ou non sinon on se retrouve avec
une courte point de tels rapports de
l'aude rapport et le gouvernement au
beau jeu de les ignorer en tout ou en
partie très bien
là c'est moi que joseph ged il a joué jo
est obligé d'être en désaccord
j'attends depuis ce matin lumière jaune
attention les sondages monsieur lebon a
baissé
moi c'est drôle mais si j'étais dans
vote dans votre ciel je ne le suis pas
mais je vais vous écoutez je trouve que
c'est bon là on va montrer sondage en
question intentions de vote de légers
donc qui a été publiée ce matin au
journal de montréal
42 il n'a perdu que 4 points monsieur la
grossesse et mon interprétation
l'exclamation que quatre points madame
en arcade il n'y a pas eu aucun gain que
gabriel nadeau-dubois un seul petit
point éric duhaime 6 points une poussée
d'éric duhaime et le parti québécois qui
poursuit sa descente à 2 points bon vous
avez le chiffre on a mis tout le chef
des francophones également sur le goût
est à 48 pour sa 12 pour cent pour les
libéraux et éric duhaime 12% 12% pour le
pq il ya égalité moi je suis monsieur
legault je regarde ça j'ai dit comment
ça se fait
josé tour de tacles ans fait que j'ai
pas plus basse et compte tenu de la
grande compte tenu de la grande des
mesures engendré par les mesures
sanitaires à tous une bonne nouvelle
pour lui là je vois pas beaucoup de
lumière jaune honnêtement ben moi j'ai
j'imagine monsieur legault fait un bond
alors oui mais oui en effet eh ben on
écoute et on est quand même à plusieurs
mois encore de l'élection on sait que
campagne électorale ce sont des boîtes à
surprises cela étant dit après 22 mois
de pandémie l'hécatombe de la première
vague la gestion chaotique de la
cinquième vague dans laquelle on vit en
ce moment sa popularité reste quand même
très forte au million pas qu'il a été
que la cape était nu en 2018 avec 47%
des voix donc moins encore que ceux qui
donnent toujours comme et et son
avantage pour le moment c'est non
seulement la division des partis
d'opposition écouter ccss les partis
d'opposition québec se seraient produits
comme des lapins là on est rendu avec le
parti conservateur du québec qui monte
qui et qui talonne le pq tel talent une
culasse et tout le monde et ça pour lui
c'est définitivement à son avantage je
pense que c'est davantage pour la
démocratie au québec par contre parce
que là ça fait des oppositions qui sont
faibles qui sont extrêmement rapides et
rui cessé de la balkanisation l'a
finalement
voté c'est un vieux beau sciences
politiques mais mais vous avez tout à
fait raison je pense que youri repas une
petit dessin mais il n'y a pas eu il n'y
aurait pas eu des airs que ça n'arrête
on serait sur mars avec l'appui on
aurait dit à monsieur les gie lait
viande à allaire sondés ça ne souhaite
pas qu'ils aient pas de descendre
non c'est sûr la lumière les jaunes
pâles disons le comme ça dans son souci
les plusieurs sondages qui montrent une
descente ce sondage le terrain semblable
magazine l'actualité
et donc on est la concordance et les
maisons de sondage qui est une belle
sont les potes tout à fait d'accord sur
l'ampleur de la baisse d'une maison à
l'autre normal mais on en paye ce temps
dans l'es2 quand vous voyez que les
libéraux ont profité pas que le parti
québécois ont profité pas que québec
solidaire en profiter un peu
puis que le parti conservateur d'éric
duhaime en profite ce que ça veut dire
c'est que les partis traditionnels
libéraux péquistes ne profite absolument
pas de ce qui se produit comme grogne et
que les plus petits partis en profite
mais évidemment il parle de tellement
loin qu'ils en profitent dans une
moindre mesure jeu d'accord avec tout ce
que josé a dit le scénario parfait de
divisions de l'opposition pour françois
legault et surtout quand on regarde chez
les francophones ceux qui suivent
françois legault 48% cki québec
solidaire 14 mémoire est bonne
12 me dis qu'à l'extérieur des comptes
et de laval puis de certains côtés de
montréal
cc c'est un massacre
partout si c'est fanny les libéraux
avaient pris 4,5 points
québec solidaire 2 3 le pq de l'e3
j'espère on arrive une tendance où les
gars mais où l'opposition se fédérer
mais la duet monsieur là on peut se dire
c'est momentané c'est là c'est la grande
sanitaire qu'il faut qu'il le gong c'est
ça ça ressemble à un mini référendum sur
les mesures sanitaires et là on voit
tout simplement la cac qui équipe a un
peu de plume parce que les gens sont en
ont ras le pompon et finalement c'est
eric de cesser duhaime qui est le parti
conservateur qui va récupérer tous les
tous les gens qui qui grognent contre
les mesures sanitaires fait que ces
seuls portraits mais en réalité c'est
qu'on partait la caq partait de
tellement haut avant noël on leur
donnait pratiquement 100 députés la
prochaine élection et c'était le trois
quarts des circonscriptions l'on n'a pas
vu ça depuis les années 80 l'élection de
de robert bourassa dans son camp mais
c'est quand même énorme qui perdent un
peu de plumes ça va peut-être même faire
plaisir à monsieur legault parce que
d'avoir un caucus aussi nombreux ça fait
ça fait beaucoup de ça fait beaucoup de
surveillance a
finalement c'est
l'analyse j'allais dire à la mode mais
qu' ils peignent pasco bye bye reid
sommes sur le goût mais lisez avait une
bonne ligne aux mordus ce midi l'elysée
jean françois wendling 10h et legault ne
veut pas avoir une écrasante majorité le
député bénac a signé son intention de
faire une proportionnelle qui ne veut
plus
ça se fera pas
il propose plus ce que c'était que c'est
que les premiers ministres précédents
même rené lévesque et ont reculé cela
étant dit il ya quand même comédie avec
le petit voyant jaune pâle il est quand
même là et il est justement sur la
question de la gestion de la pandémie et
lorsque c'est ce qu'est ce que ça dit à
monsieur legault je sais pas s'ils vont
suivre cet avis l'homme est ce que c'est
bien monsieur legault c'est que il doit
absolument
remettre redresser son gouvernail pour
la cinquième vague avoir de meilleures
communications et que ces mesures soient
plus cohérent plus clair je vais mettre
l'adresse qui me reste du temps pour
souffler lire le rapport dont on parle
est la commissaire à la santé et au
bien-être le rapport d'un castonguay
haskell il est le lien ce qu'on peut le
mettre devant le maître au retour de la
pause on va le mettre autour de la cause
je vous le remettre le retour de la
pause ah ben voilà oh là là on va leur
mettre retour de la pause à tout merci à
vous trois salut
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit